One more concept that we're going to need is the idea of power.
This is a word you've heard a lot like force or energy, but now, let's put a real definition to it.
Power measures how quickly work can be done!
And what I mean by that is, let's say if two people and there's a pile of rocks.
Let's say, this first person is more powerful than the second person.
Even though, if you give them bought a sufficient amount of time,
they can move all these rocks up to, let's say, this basket here.
If person 1 is more powerful, they'll do it faster.
And so the equation for power is work divided by how long it takes to do that work, we call it Δt.
Let's say this first person can lift one of these rocks,
one of these 2 kg rock, a height of 15 m in 30 secs, what is their power?
The units of a power are watts. Watt is just another term for joules per second. Enter your answer here.